Ted Cruz you might know him as the
silver medalist in this elections hate
Olympics oh he's mad about that silver
mostly because he's allergic to it also
garlic and sunlight but he's the guy
establishment Republicans want as their
white knight in shining armor to save
them from an actual white knight with a
spray tan and now in an attempt to rude
Trump voters Cruz is using the Brussels
attacks to execute his most desperate
play yet a Hail Mary if you will he said
well we need to empower law enforcement
to patrol and secure Muslim
neighborhoods before they become
radicalized there's an original idea
surveilling Muslims also known as the
free center tile on Republican talking
points bingo but Cruz doesn't have the
best track record when it comes to
originality if Donald wants to get in a
character fight he's better off sticking
with me cause Heidi is way out of his
League do you want a character debate
Bob you better stick with me cuz Sydney
Ellen Wade is way out of your league
he's got that on VHS with an idea this
bold surely he's put a lot of thought
into this plan how many Muslims are in
America I don't know the number i'll
stop ahead 3.3 million but who's
counting come on ask him something more
specific name one community one city
where we have a large group of
radicalized message you you have
communities you have communities for
example in Minnesota you have
communities in Michigan huh Minnesota
and Michigan now some might say those
are more States than cities to which I'd
say you say potato I say Idaho let's
call the whole thing vague the point is
he wants to start patrolling and
securing what he calls Muslim
neighborhoods and even if he can't
explain it based on his love of Michael
Douglas films it would probably look
something like this
why are you running if you have nothing
to hide it seems the only thing that
Cruz blames more than American Muslims
for violence is political correctness
people are fed up with the political
correctness political correctness of
this administration politically correct
gain political correctness cost lives
yes cuz if I can't say the n-word in
public I will die blaming political
correctness for the attacks in Brussels
is kind of far-fetched but then again so
is elected a man who eats ice cream like
this I need the glucose for my
hatchlings let me just take a moment to
talk political correctness and Islam cuz
you gotta wonder was it politically
correct to invade to predominantly
Muslim countries or train random rebels
in a third or strike a fourth with
drones or send weapons to a fifth to
suppress a sixth all while sanctioning
his seventh and casting Christian Bale
to play Moses his name is literally
Christian given all that it seems like
not that tall of an order to not trail
Muslims everywhere they go in the end of
the day cruises plan to secure in patrol
sound straight out of a narrow way
before our time an era of suspicion when
everything was black and white
you